Tương tâm dự báo khi tượng thủy văn Quốc gia cho biết, từ tháng 12.000,
nắng nắng có suy rứng gia tăng và mở giọng gia nhiều khu vực trên cả nước,
đặc biệt tại Vác Bộ và Trung Bộ.
Tương tâm đến nửa đầu tháng 12, khu vực phía vác tiếp tục chuyện hưởng của các đợt không ký lạnh,
cho khi nắng đã xuất hiện sớm tại Nà Bộ.
Cụ thể, từ tháng một đến nửa đầu tháng 12, đã có tâm đợt không ký lạnh,
anh hưởng đến Vác Bộ và Vác Trung Bộ.
Gây ra hai đợt sẽ đầm giết hại trên diện rộng.
Dạy đợt thấp nhất phục đến trong các đợt sẽ từ tâm đến mở tổ xe,
vùng lũi, năm đến bài độ xe, vùng lũi cao có nơi dưới bụng độ xe.
Ở chium ngược lại, khu vực lưng nằm bộ đã khi nhận nhiều ngày nắng nắng trong tháng 2,
đây được sắc định là đợt nắng giận dọt đầu tiên trong năm 2020,
và xuất hiện sớm hơn so với Trung Bình nhiều năm.
Cơ quan khi tượng dự báo, từ tháng 3 đến tháng 6,
dạy đợt Trung Bình trên phạm vi cạnh nước phục đến sắp xí Trung Bình nhiều năm,
dính bắt bộ và khu vực từ thành hóa đến nghệ ăn trong tháng 3,
có thể cao hơn từ khu vệ năm đến mộ độ xe.
Nắng nắng được dự báo ra tăng từ tháng 3, trước hết tại đông năm bộ,
sau đó mở giọng sang tìnhuyên, tên năm bộ, rồi lan ra khu vực bắt bộ và Trung Bộ từ quý tháng 6,
với cường độ tăng dần trong các tháng tiếp theo.